[Jeff Goldblum] Hmm.
Hmm.
(laughter and applause)
Hello there, I'm so glad you could join me today.
I'm Leonard Meshbesher--
(laughter)
The psychotherapist to the superheroes.
They call me renowned.
In any case, take a look at some of these sessions,
and you'll see the kind of work that goes on here.
So, I'm sensing some tension
between the two of you right now.
Yes, I'm right?
[Professor X] She's been very passive-aggressive with me.
You've got to be very frank and direct,
can you do that, Storm?
You know, we can't read your mind.
Well, (chuckles) maybe he can.
(electricity sizzles)
Storm?
Are you controlling my humidifier again?
I don't want you to do that, Storm.
Storm? Thank you.
Superheroes help other people.
That's what they're in the business to do.
But so often, they've got issues around Dada.
Daddy issues. Dada.
How did it feel, is my question, Luke,
when you declared a boundary with your father.
[Luke] He cut off my hand.
I sure would like you to use those I feel statements.
I feel bad, I feel sad, I feel--
[Luke] I feel like flipping you off right now.
Both of you.
Okay, could have been more effective,
I don't know why you didn't use the good hand.
You could do a flip off much more effectively there.
That reminds me of one of those
hotel ding ding ding ding ding,
doesn't it, in the lobby?
You know what I judge your essential
struggle to be?
[Jon] What's that?
I think it has something to do with your dad.
If he were here right now in this room with us,
what would you say to him?
[Jon] I don't know.
I'm not just a bastard.
You're not just a bastard.
I've got a surprise for you, Jon Snow.
He's right here.
Here's your dad, let's talk.
(cheers and applause)
Trust that they will catch you, ready and ...
And now Peter.
And now just totally let go, go.
[Spider-Man] Assholes.
And what'd you learn from that?
Life is unpredictable.
When it comes to mental health, don't be a hero.
You get it?
Call the Institute, and there you go.
There you go, right there, right there.
Because, and one more final word,
sometimes the greatest superpower--
[Old Man] Hey!
Dad?
Who are you talking to?
Dad, I've asked you (bleeps).
I've asked when I'm working to not interrupt me.
Can I ever have some (bleeps) privacy--
All right, all right.
When I'm trying to work.
Your mother wants you to know that dinner is ready.
Oh, okay. Sorry.
Ah, I know where I was.
Sometimes the greatest superpower
is being a great listener.
(enthusiastic applause)
That man is a genius.
I bow to that man.